you want to create a safe living
learning environment for the community
because the soil that we're trying to
develop it's actually the community so
you want to start with healthy soil a
healthy community so becoming a seed to
supper facilitator it's more than just
gardening it's about community
development
it's about community education it's
about community empowerment and in
Parker Palmer's book healing the heart
of democracy the courage to create a
politics worthy of the human spirit he
talks about these five habits of the
heart and these five habits can be used
as a road map to develop a community
garden but also to create a community
community rivers have to understand that
the community garden is about everyone
and the success of the garden is about
everyone and that we're all in the
gardening we're all in the community
together not one person sticks out we
have to stick together in order to
create our community but also it's an
appreciation of the value of everyone
everybody comes into a community
different everyone's story is different
everyone's food choice is different but
we have to address this to understand
appreciate that diversity but then also
with diversity comes tension in the
third habit of the heart is an ability
to hold tension in life-giving ways
tension can arise but there's a way to
use that tension and create a community
through tension and actually recycled
attention and devote that tension to
actually developing a community garden
developing community education efforts
around the garden but then the fourth
habit of the heart is a sense of
personal voice and agency when we honor
life when we honor people's agencies
when we honor their voices and their
personal backgrounds we create community
so for people who are going into
communities that are not used to the
process of being self reflexive has to
occur because you're gonna come up
against things that you're not used to
and you have to be sensitive to that
going to the fifth heaven of the heart
which is the capacity to create
community which is when we when we honor
life when we honor people's agencies
when we honor their voices
and their personal backgrounds we create
community but creating community is not
a one-time thing it's a continuous
process it's a process of recreating and
rethinking and reimagining where the
community is
you